I started working with a blood testing
company about 6 months ago in America
and I knew I wanted to do more
preventative medicine all the rest of it
get my Bloods done never had my tea
levels done came back at 495 so I'm in
the normal range but I'm at the like low
end of normal they put me on a protocol
which didn't include trt but like I
needed to take Boron to free at my free
and I needed to do like pharmaceutical
grade of magnesium glycinate because the
version I was using wasn't converted and
some amga slser and more organ meats and
I got my results P about 2 weeks ago and
it was at 1,06 so it's gone from $495 to
06 and the felt difference in my mood in
my energy libido everything is
palpable realizing that Oh I thought
that that was life I thought that was
normal everything at the moment seems to
be very conducive toward men not being
able to psychologically physically
hormonally socially archetypally embody
anything that is traditionally masculine
ultimately it's not just guys that will
struggle like if one sex loses both
sexes lose